foreign
well what do you make of it what's
happened to this Village I witnessed a
site much the same in my infancy
the oppression of the weak
murder and pillage unchecked
making Nightmare
made by men put this time
I'm a woman grown and though the
suffering cannot be undone I can still
meet out justice justice to the
oppressors
scars I carve remind them
I am nepheli Lou Warrior
[Music]
ah goodness me I
I'm out of us
and I'll be norik as you can see we're
finished
the whole village is finished
the curse mongers have destroyed
everything
no one that remains as their wits about
them
look after this medallion
you must keep it out of the curse
magazines
and if you should meet the young
albinoreklatena then please give it to
her
a chosen land awaits us albinorex The
Medallion is the key that leads to the
city it's only a quaint treasure for we
who cannot make the journey
but for dear Latana
it is needed
to fulfill her purpose
My legs will soon fade
and with them my life
alas
this is the immovable fate of all
albinorex
foreign
[Music]
what do you want
I told the old hearing Brute
that I possess no such medallion
[Music]
or have you come to take more from me
it wasn't me as a half not enough
oh
do you speak true so old Albus entrusted
his Medallion tear
then I have no choice but to trust that
this was his dying will let's try again
I'm lieutenant
an albanoric the same as old Albus my
apologies for my courseworks earlier
I presume the worst
seen that you're another tarnished like
that all-hearing Brute
foreign
I hope that you will forgive me
would you consider doing me a great
service I must go back there is
something I must do
even if I must say farewell to my wolf
lover will you show me the way
to the land of Nicholas hay Lake tree
then I suppose it's time
farewell local
my faithful wolf
my better half I will go with the
tarnished
so that our journey will not have been
in vain
forgive me and over
call upon me when needed
and I will fight at your side
are you
please let me be
pathetic I know but I
need to think
[Music]
you've already heard
indeed it seemed the well-powered
suspicions so I had no further use for
it honestly what a man to do a
determined plebeian is more morgue than
an almond
quite frankly I suspect that's just what
the queen wants a dose of ambition to
inside that's harnessed
[Music]
I presume the worst
seeing that you're another tarnished
like that all hearing root
[Music]
you know already
[Music]
it's true
my father cast me out for indulging my
emotions
forgetting the mission
punishment for offing his pawns father
Lord Gideon has offered me guidance all
my life I would have done anything for
him
to place him on the throne of Elden Lord
and yet I
oh it was not my intent I betrayed him
and I
can no longer trust him father to think
he'd ordered his men to enact such
tragedy
where is the Justice he departs in that
he once told me that if he became Eldon
Lord he would never allow the
downtrodden to be cheated ever again
was he simply lying to me
no no no
how could I say that father has always
given me his guidance and now
I've lost it
do you hear me
it is I Lieutenant we're almost there
Castle Soul lies just off to the north
where the other Medallion is housed
foreign
passage to the land of the healing tree
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a young yet towering sister of us
let the birthing droplet in
and create life
for us for all the algonorix
thank you I finally fulfilled my purpose
our young yet tiring sister will give us
hope
now that nothing is left unfinished I
will join you in battle to The Bitter
End and when the fighting is done then
you may lay me to rest
beside Lobo
My Dear Wolf
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]